And the answer is you can. It must be 1100.
The way to see that is if you look at the x values, there are three that match 0111.
Those must correspond to the output where x = 0,
because we know an AND gate has three outputs that have a value 0.
And then there's one that has the value 1011
that must correspond to the x value having the output 1,
and that means the only way the output could be 1 is if both of these represent 1.
That means we know the value of b1. That's this one.
The value of b0 must be the other one, which is 1100.
We can, in fact, deduce all the lines in the truth table from this pattern.
So obviously this doesn't work.
We're not hiding in the patterns that are inherent in the logic functions we're computing
by replacing them with random numbers as we have to do something so this table is harder to see.
And what we have to do is make it so the outputs are encrypted,
so that we can't tell the values of the other entries in the truth table.
We can only tell the value of the one that we actually evaluate
and that hides whether it matches any of the other values.